i think it's encouraging that we're  creating jobs in britain and the  overwhelming majority of those jobs are  going to british nationals who are being  trained and educated in our schools and  are ready for the workforce so over the  last year something like 70 of the new  jobs more than 70 percent have gone to  british people that's good news  obviously we have to wait and see what  happens with these uh figures from  romania and bulgaria and what have you  uh but i think the best thing we can do  is get rid of benefit tourism in europe  that's part of my goal but we've got to  realize that a proper immigration policy  needs a proper welfare policy so it  doesn't pay to be idle and it needs a  proper education policy